άνωταςπο αδόπουλος ζούσε σήμερα θρωήτα ότι θα σθα στενοχωρια όταν ή θα θα τον ενοχλούσε
κάποια πράγματα που υπάρχουν σήμερα στην πολιτική ζωή του τόπου μπολι μπρεί να ηπια ράματα
μπο κάποια πράγματα να μην τοννα το μποεί να τον ενοχλούσαν σίγουρεσίγουρ ο ίδιος θα
έλεγε αυτό που θα το θα τον ενοχλούσαν αλλά σίγουρα η κατάσταση μαση γενικά έχουμε
αυτός τους πολέμους γεγώ μας η κατάσταση είναι παρα πολύ δύσκολη για την κύπρο αυτή
τη στιγμή επιστεύω είναι και μεγαλή τομάχι ήταν τον κύπριακό ήναενα τον ενοχλούσε ιστα σημότητα
ή συζήτηση σήγορα σίγουρα θα ήθελει και κίνος νομίζω ότι όλοι θέλουμε να γίνει κάτι
για τοκύπρι κοδεμίζω να υπάρχει άνθωπος που να μη θέλε θέλει να να εληθεί αυτό
τοπολύ σοβαο θέμανα το θέμα είναι να γίνει σωστά και να πραγματικά να επανενωθούμε αι
να ζήσουμε όλοι μαζίσε μια έχω ευχαριστώ παράπολύ αυτή τη συζήτηση για κάποιες πτυχές που
ανοίξατε μέσα από την πλούσια ζωή σας να στε καλά ευχαριστο πάρα πολύπου απόδεκτικά ησημένη
πρόσκληση και εγώ σας ευχαλιστώ φιλές και φίλι άλλο ένα αντεναλλά υθα ποτκασέφταση το τέλος
του να ευχαριστήσουμε και σήμερα τα αν πειν υπάρχουν ήταν στην παρέα μας τα λέμε
την ερχόμενα εβδομάδα με τον επιχειρηματία τον κύριον την ο λευχαρίστηα